tous
avec emmanuel faux soeur emmanuelle vous
recevez le porte parole du modem de
françois bayrou
yann wehrling bonsoir yann wehrling un
nouveau sondage indique que le front
national pourrait enlever trois régions
le 6 et le 13 décembre prochain en plus
du nord pas de calais picardie et de la
provence alpes côte d'azur le grand test
semble aussi désormais à portée de main
de l'extrême droite ou florian philippot
arriverait devant les listes du parti
des républicains et devant les listes de
la gauche emmenée par le ps
ça vous inquiète bien évidemment le la
montée du front national est un sujet
inquiétant mais ont d'abord une petite
remarque d'ailleurs au passage doit
quand même souligner que si le mode de
scrutin était resté intégralement
proportionnelle cette question ne se
poserait pas on construirait des
coalitions de certainement de larges de
large coalition et il y aurait pas de
questions de régions qui pourraient être
emportés par le front national sans être
majoritaire parce que c'est quand même
ça les cas de figure c'est que le front
national pourrait remporter des régions
l'ambulance voilà le 13 décembre
prochain
en n'étant pas majoritaire en faisant
pas 50% donc c'est quand même une
question démocratique qu'on peut se
poser est ce que ça naturellement sans
se poser de questions se dit que en
faisant pas 50% pour remporter une
élection qui est celle importante d'une
élection régionale en même temps la
proportionnelle avec primo au vainqueur
donne toujours un avantage à celui qui
arrive en tête
oui mais c'est un artifice de primes qui
fait que en faisant moins de 50% -peut
être majoritaire dans l'assemblée après
bon cela étant le sujet c'est quand même
de ceux de débattre de cette question
aujourd'hui du front national et de
l'intérêt de beaucoup trop d'électeurs
pour cette formation politique et on ne
débat pas assez à mon avis du programme
de ce parti
on est toujours sur une stigmatisation
un petit peu facile mais il faut débat
du programme de ce parti
je note que le medef aujourd'hui à fait
est sorti
a fait une sortie sur la question du
début du programme économique du front
national
donc c'est important d'aller dans le
détail de ce que propose le front
national en l'occurrence sur les
questions économiques
oui la proposition du front national est
un danger pour le pays pour son
développement économique et pour la
création d'emplois mais encore un mot en
termes de stratégie électorale ce cas
votre avis au vu de ces chiffres de ces
tendances de ce climat que l'on connaît
actuellement il faut revoir la stratégie
anti fn est peut-être envisager un front
républicain droite gauche entre les deux
tours dans plusieurs régions ça j'en
sais rien je sais que il faut pas non
plus que les électeurs aient le
sentiment qu'ils alimenteraient
d'ailleurs le discours du front national
ils sont tous ensemble en réalité il
faut que ce soit basée sur un accord de
fond il faut qu'on construise quelque
chose sur la durée que ce soit crédible
et vis-à-vis des électeurs on peut pas
s'affronter pendant des semaines et des
mois et des mois et tout d'un coup
s'entendre au dernier moment c'est
compliqué peut-être que ce sera
nécessaire j'en sais rien en vain mais
c'est compliqué moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'on construit ça il faut qu'on
construise une offre politique nouvelle
dans ce pays qu'ils soient réformiste
responsable et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le cas c'est pas tout à fait le cas
honnêtement donc il va falloir qu'on
avance sur cette idée là mais qu'on soit
en transparence vis-à-vis des électeurs
alors le contexte des attentats
évidemment ne rend pas très audible le
message des différents partis dans cette
campagne si campanile il ya d'ailleurs
est ce que pour vous modem vous pouvez
faire passer un message particulier dans
cette période qui marque avant tout par
la préoccupation sécuritaire et par le
souci de cohésion nationale je crois que
bien sûr les élections régionales
de dimanche prochain n'auront pas tout à
fait la même allure que s'il n'y avait
pas eu les attentats du 13 novembre
pour autant je crois que 1 des messages
quand même à adresser aux français c'est
de leur dire ce que les terroristes ont
cherché à viser c'est eu un pays une
démocratie une république avec des
valeurs parmi ces valeurs il ya la
démocratie justement et la démocratie
c'est les urnes c'est aller aux
élections et donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que le 6 décembre 13
décembre faut que les électeurs aillent
aux urnes pour pas qu'ils aient peur
faut qu'ils envoient un message de 2,2 à
ces gens qui ne pour le qui le mot
démocratie ne veut rien dire et voir et
qu'il le combat il faut leur dire voilà
nous on est une démocratie on va voter
ça je suis vic un message civique un mec
message d'engagement qui montre que les
électeurs vont aller aux urnes et
envoyer un message bien sûr totalement
contraire à ce que les hétéros qu'ils
veulent entendre c'est un message de
peur nous n'avons pas peur et c'est ce
qu'il faut leur envoyer moi je modem
plutôt que notre parti dans ce message
civique comme et tous les partis doivent
adresser ce message mais moi je
l'adresse particulièrement ici au nom de
mon parti bien sûr j'avais envie que je
n'oublie pas et vous non plus que vous
avez été membre des verts même porte
parole national des écologistes il ya
une dizaine d'années est-ce que vous
pensez que la coque 21 et bien embarquée
malgré les divergences convoi persister
entre les uns et les autres le nord et
le sud notamment et une certaine
rigidité des états unis ça les problèmes
moi je souhaite qu'il y ait un accord je
souhaite qu'on avance mais coop 21 veut
dire que c'est la 21e fois qu'on se
retrouve pour discuter de ces questions
là et honnêtement on n'a pas beaucoup
avancé en 21 ans un joug donne un
chiffre depuis ses 21 années passées
bien avant aussi on aimait à peu près 2
5% de plus de gaz à effet de serre par
an à l'échelle planétaire donc c'est
pour vous dire que les efforts ne sont
pas au rendez vous donc je crois que un
des éléments que moi je note
malheureusement dans cette coop 21 c'est
que les états et la france en
particulier les pouvoirs publics en
particulier n'ont pas suscité d'intérêt
chez les français honnêtement quand vous
en parler autour de vous ce n'est pas le
sujet numéro un dont parlent les
français aujourd'hui la coop vainqueur
alors même que c'est en ce moment même à
paris
et donc il faut aussi qu'il ya un élan
citoyen une envie de faire il n'y a pas
cette envie au jour
lui est par ailleurs le signe de
pressions sur les dirigeants et
gouvernements
oui parce qu'ils les électeurs les
dirigeants sont issus des urnes donc ils
ont besoin d'une pression populaire pour
agir aujourd'hui et quelle pression ils
ont elle est assez faible
et j'ajouterai que c'est difficile
d'arriver à un accord puisque l'intérêt
de la planète aujourd'hui il n'est pas
défendu dans cette coop 21 la somme des
intérêts de chaque état la somme des
égoïsmes de chaque état ne fera pas un
intérêt planétaire donc je suis un peu
sceptique sur lui si je suis critique
sur le principe même de ces conférences
internationales qui ne donne rien faut
qu'on passe à des actions peut-être plus
concrètes plus palpable lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire arrêter les
subventions aux énergies fossiles c'est
des mesures simples concrètes
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être plus
crédible que de s'engager pour quelque
chose qui aura lieu en 2050 avec des
chefs d'état qui s'engage aujourd'hui
qui ne sera évidemment plus là pour
répondre de ses engagements quand on
arrivera à l'échéance de 2050
un dernier mot nous sommes aujourd'hui
le jour de la journée mondiale de lutte
contre le sida comme chaque 1er décembre
on entendu tout à l'heure mélanie gomes
dans le journal qui nous rappelait que
aujourd'hui encore en france les
séropositifs sont interdits d'un certain
nombre de professions comme notamment
celle de magistrats est ce que ça vous
choque
yann wehrling oui je pense que c'est un
anachronisme et que c'est peut-être un
point sur lequel il faut revenir
rapidement parce que ça ne se justifie
évidemment aucunement qu'il y ait ce
type de discrimination à l'égard des
personnes atteintes du sida donc on
découvre en voilà régulièrement ce genre
de choses et c'est bien que vous médias
pointier ce problème pour que rapidement
on corrige ccc situation vous remercie
yann wehrling d'être revenus dans un
repli
sur europe 1 après un tour du monde à la
communauté internationale